well we know this but take a look at our
aviator drone video from the damage of
flash flooding this is in the overton
and logandale area the community there
gathering to clean up the neighborhoods
alongside the
clark county commission chairman marilyn
kirkpatrick was
out there along with the moapa valley
fire district crews all
donning their shovels and cleaning up on
tuesday night water was four to five
feet in some areas eight news now talked
to a family who had just
moved to overton a couple of weeks ago
the kids were watching
the storm kind of commence on our front
on our back porch and
all of a sudden the sky turned gray and
then the torrential downpour
the rain was actually going diagonal to
the point that we shut all our curtains
and everything else got away from the
glass
when i was videoing and showing somebody
what was going on
the screen blew and that was enough that
we decided not to watch anymore
a flood control project is in the works
now in order to help that community